and we are back I have Grandmaster
Ludwick joining all for the call
Oh God how's it going how's it going hey
I just got back from he cars I was try
to help him out weird weird that his
power went out I did the best that I
could but what are you gonna do I guess
I have to do it now I guess we have to
have me on so you know watch the first
game the first set went great
yeah this is gonna be interesting change
of pace for me because normally I'm like
oh so here in the car what do you think
and he gives me something about Magnus
Carlsen I can't wait to hear when I
asked you that question so love it what
do you think about it Corrin and Magnus
Carlsen I can't wait for you to tell me
the chest history yeah well look I can I
can I can bring up anything you want you
want me to you want me to bring up the
1851 oh that's the only one I know they
took 5,200 mortal game I got you covered
but I dunno both the players that are
coming up here I've played him buff I've
lost to him both to be frank so I think
I won't this ain't like that like a
there's a close ot but I think I I have
a lot of insight of what's about to
happen I was watching slicker earlier I
think he's gonna go for an early mate I
think it might be the same from moist
critical I think it's gonna be a
firework show and early made from a
brick got it and I mean you know both
flare as well you've put them in chess
you probably them in many other eSports
I assume yeah sure have you so have you
lost them anything besides chest um no
well I I lose like like a cool contest
to critical about all I got by the way
before we before I think we're jumped in
production you forgot to put GM like
right yeah there's a GM missing from
from just yeah I'm actually pretty upset
about that too I know I know what do you
have to do to get to get a title around
here I you you ask and you shall receive
I feel like is what's about to happen
so d6 played by slicker protecting a
center so loving so far everything
looking normal to you yeah I think this
is fine I think I think if I'm critical
here I'm feeling great I love when I
play e4 and they play
five that's the only thing I want to
have happen at this point you got so
many options that's great too I love
doing that so what's the what's the idea
of d6 cuz now I can just take with night
and then I feel like I have more
advancements so I guess slicker wanted
to bring the bishop out early so he
opened up the diagonal for his bishop
but you're right that opening with the
Knights out of the pawn to d6 would have
been better you better control over the
center mm-hmm and well if you had the
white side of this position what would
your thought process be like I hate
chasing out that dump bishop all right
makes me waste my time and then the
bishop just ends in a good spot where
it's attacking your pawn anyway so I
much prefer to like put my bishop to cut
him off okay at my level but I think I
had sorry I had a GM call it dainty once
or soft I forget who I believe it was oh
not a GM sorry a professional dater
Alex potes said that once that's that's
why it might not have been the right
call but that's why I don't I don't uh I
don't know if it's the right move well
let me assume a time management because
both of these players are moving really
quickly and if we just go back white
took a pawn on e5 black one f6 instead
of reacting to either the pawn captures
critical went Knight c3 and then slicker
went g5 yeah this is a crazy amount of
blunders happening back to back to back
it feels like they're playing their
three Oh game and they I'm shocked
that critical is not seen just like just
taking a pawn you don't need him to be
stacked you just get a free pawn right
and he's already took one pawn to begin
with so Hilton end up doing a trade
he'll be up a pawn here but Bishop c4
his credit is a good move because he's
getting his Bishop out into the open and
g4 slickers holding nothing back yet
slicker just seems to be advancing
non-stop I don't super understand it uh
you know it obviously was protected by
the pawn already but he's he's gone for
blood and I respect that because we saw
in the game with hutch that if you play
a little too passive you might not find
a mate and you might end up in a tough
situation but I think this will be very
different I think we're gonna see a lot
more blunders today well let's listen
here slickers thoughts because he's
always entertaining
this hair I can't find yo when you see
the enemy's creep up man don't do nothin
but you know just say you know mice
critical he's gonna feel that moist he's
gonna feel that moistness okay me
threatened this if I move this here no
cuz he's playing a small game but what
am i doing I need to pull out my enemies
out so I need to get this out I need to
get no this out the cool movies gonna be
a queen there think bro think I don't
want to disrespect he's gonna do rock
think he's gonna do rock think come on
bro I can't lose this man I got this for
the boy damn I got this for the boy damn
goodness for the boy them maybe maybe
he's smart maybe he's not but maybe he
ain't as smart cuz yo was words of
wisdom my slicker they're everything
he's saying I'm agreeing with vehemently
if I leave this here okay okay that's
fine that's fine that's fine
was he trying to do is this a check cuz
I'm not doing that
hey car is leave the car if you're
watching he is his little buster little
Cochino GM not to reduce Kirksey okay GM
that hazardous risk is key okay cuz
listen I see what you done and you don't
know what you did what
pretty sure that's correct pronunciation
of the British accent anyway yeah yeah
yeah I think it was something
intelligent I'm sure I mean you've heard
how they say Tuesday it's just it's the
British way it's charming charming is
one way of putting it but the slicker
you know he his position actually isn't
that bad anymore if he takes this pawn
on e5 yeah I'll tell you a real problem
that that that slickers having and it's
that he's an entertainer yeah
and so NIM once told me the sage NIM
said that hey
the other and the other ponents doing
their move you should think of what to
do but slicker no no no he doesn't do
that he starts saying things to
entertain his chat that's all he's
concerned about he's a I think he was
dropping bars for a bit there yes and
he's known to dance quite a lot oh yeah
yeah so I think he's he's not he's not
really being like okay well here's a
pawn here I could take this and less he
defends it he's like what your rude boy
he got not knut and then he's more
focused on that than the game I had
which I get because I do the same thing
sometimes while while I'm streaming the
chess match yeah I was watching you play
chess last night and seemed like you
were a little distracted but you also
were you know you're saying that people
blunder a lot right if you make a lot of
mistakes and here for instance this pawn
to e5
has been here forever diss epona it can
be captured by black and white can
decide to capture pawn so why do you
think they're not looking at those pawns
you think they just forgot about them I
think it comes down to what you it's
your fault
Robert mine rest of the GMs you taught
us to develop our pieces and so that's
what these guys are doing and they're
doing great all the pieces have been
activated on the white side both sides
of castled but at no point do they think
oh let me just look at the board and see
if someone did some dumb that's what the
lesson we needed they're gonna do dumb
let's try to find it well thank you for
coaching me on how to coach I'm gonna I
think that one to heart okay I'm sorry
well you you look right today I mean
that sincerely I because I need to you
know make sure that everyone's ready I
need to coach you so I'm getting ready
for your match for tomorrow it's X you
see cuz you know that car is not
prepping you yeah it it does feel like
he cars getting prepped by le from the
last of us to or whatever her name is so
I I'm not too worried about that I am
worried about what's happened it was
critical though all right well let's
tune into here critical thoughts went
here earlier with my queen and
not good I think I just got too focused
on one thing in particular all right
what are we looking for we're looking at
this
is he just completely silent right now
he's he's just sullen III think he's
thinking though which is good to do
I would agree thinking is generally a
good thing to do yeah it's making me
uncomfortable how quiet he is I like the
way he's he's pensive though it's like
touching his lips softly considering
various options if you're gonna have
facial hair like that
you got a stroke bro it would be a waste
and that's coming from someone who grows
peach fuzz this once he takes that he's
deep in thought so he scanning the board
for his opponent's ideas which is good
he's not getting obsessed with a single
plan yeah it feels like there's a
statute of limitations in chess oh no
way maybe take why wouldn't you I guess
I feel like he forgot that that pawn
took upon and it's like there's a
statute of limitations in the crimes no
longer you can't get arrested for it and
so it's like it's reset it's reset and
all of a sudden he's like okay well I
can't have to ignore 'if I've obviously
oh it's it's almost like when he shut
off his brain he knew what to do and he
just he finally took the pawn hey
gripped and ripped it I think you did a
good point though about forgetting that
he captured upon there so to him he just
seems like a pawn tree and he's like
wait why would I want to trade my pawn
they lost my points Knight get out I'm
still convinced that he did not know
that that was a positive trade for him I
still thinks that was like a 1 to 1 pawn
trade even if it wasn't oh this is bad
on the meter the meter went down why
Robert oh you're the gym Mike Jim
co-commentator so you tell me well well
right back up so let's forget about it
we can glaze on past it I was gonna tell
the chat but we don't need to worry
about it boys cuz there was another
blunder
so Bishop takes Knight and f3 would have
removed the defender from the Michelin
g5 and so if you take back which is what
you want to do you lose this Bishop on
g5 so it's actually losing a piece
in the process and you would want to
take an f6 to keep going but then my
queen comes out and check me
mmm simple case of checkers chess do you
say checkers no I meant to say I'm gonna
say like a smart chess word but I
couldn't I don't know man all I've been
reading in chat today is that he car
with the glasses and people saying chess
mate so my my words have fallen off I
don't know the words anymore did you
really just say checkers come on man we
don't gotta get into the weeds of it you
know we're just having fun here you know
we are we are and also this tactic with
Bishop takes f3 is still out here yeah
it keeps going down but I don't think
he'll find it so it's just kind of like
a fun like I don't even know what bounce
is this much a thermometer if you switch
it between a sick child and a healthy
child perhaps having a basketball
normally my thing about basketball about
if that's a good one let's go with
basketball okay just the first thing
that came to mind the trampoline you
bouncing that oh yeah trip leads good
two trampolines get to hey we all come
up with our own ideas Robert mine was
also like good in a way
he's just supported me today I almost
don't like it I feel like there's I need
you to start just ragging on me at some
I'm just try to get on your good side
all right I'll spill the tea okay you
think he Cara's power went out
magically you think Alex magically got
the spot to go on the raw show you think
this was all an accident Robert I'm
trying to make some things happen all
right watch your back buddy I'm your
next for me
your nest I'm I'm coming for I'm trying
to solo commentate all chess matches for
the rest of time I mean I can just
bounce right now maybe not maybe not
maybe not eat five by Moore's critical
here he gives up his pawn the center
yeah that was a simple case of not
counting there's three defenders and two
attackers liquor because he just stole
upon the center he's probably really
that what that was a good line there
like I was just listening the music the
whole time he didn't say a single words
the first time I've ever heard
well not hurt I've never seen slicker be
quiet
yeah that was that was deep thought and
uh and it that was that was very
educational for me to listen to UK wrap
whatever site not the first time no I I
do listen to the best of the best
so you know ksi dropped some bars
occasionally I gotta take a listen
alright just see who he's dissing I
think we need to hear more of that rap
so I think we gotta bring slicker back
on yeah that's freaks I'm doubt it bring
slicker but just no clips chat no clips
whatever you do alright
Oh true well by the way would you be
clipping anyway we're gonna hey man
listens UK rap
that was great Magister rap nothing
beats it uh now I do have a question for
you Robert
is there a cool tactic you can do here
as black by pushing your Bishop to h3
yes bishop h3 because the pawn on g2 is
pinned and so once the bishop gets to h3
you'll have to react there so also
slicker was more focus in the chest and
I've never seen him I think he just
needs a listen to rap and any improves
yeah
yeah I do I do think the rap is helping
him he seems to be in the zone because
he's not worried about entertaining
that's what I'm telling you it's hard to
be a streamer you got to focus on your
chat because if you don't they like
complain or something cuz they're not
entertaining them even though it's free
and then they give you money anyway and
then they want you to thank them Robert
it's a lot of work it's a lot it's a
real job it definitely seems that way
and you know what else is a lot of work
is trying to figure out this chest
position because well when I look at
this position I see that the pieces are
all over the place and loaded for you
right this Queen on e4 looks pretty good
I'm guessing but the Queen on g7 you
point out this Bishop on h3 tactic yeah
what kind of ideas are you seeing for
both sides here in addition to Bishop h3
for some reason I'm looking at the robot
thing on the left the trampoline and a I
see the tactic with black I think that's
good I guess it just gets stopped by g3
with the pawn ma but I don't see many
ideas with with white immediately I
think you'd have to create something by
I don't know I'd bring like maybe Queen
to like be 400 they show did that
there's another bar junks whose main six
so where do you think that maid is
coming from so now there you see it on
the bar so we're you know we're wood
white deliver a checkmate I assume you
would bring your knight to put them in
check on e7 and gets taken by Queen and
then you can move your queen
to the a8 file which
put him in check he's forced to move
because there's no interposition he'll
have 200 its mate right there yeah oh
he's a club
so after 97 check you actually any moves
Queen so the thing is right we have in
evaluation bar or you're doing a puzzle
you know there's a solution but nobody's
sitting there telling critical hey man
you have a check made of six move so how
does to find it it's really hard to when
you're Queens under attack to move
another piece yeah it's it would be
absurd to have found that I think in the
scenario because you're so tunnel
visioned on just like your Queens under
pressure and that sucks but I still
think he has like a good idea here I
mean he does have a hanging a hanging
night that he's that he's attacking and
then he also has the opportunity because
he's defending the c7 square right now
to maybe do some little custom there if
you can get some pieces involved but
yeah well I just I don't think he's a
game plan yet to be honest and probably
not like a one that's like really seen
how am I gonna go check me my opponent
but you're right that White's pieces are
pretty menacing and this move Bishop e7
by slicker he was protecting the knight
on c5 he has to take back otherwise he
just lost his piece he does it and now
the King s takes was looks like refining
he realized the Queen e2 stayed to this
night but the great thing for critical
is this Bishop was pinning the Knight to
rook now there's nothing there so do you
think he'll see that his knight can yeah
100% 100% I think he's going for right
now actually he did it yeah he got it
and let's actually tune in he has the
midden half left let's hear his thoughts
this hearing was critical
he's so quiet he says so much with so
little that's like what the beautiful
thing about him is yeah it's just so
quiet but he's 95 really impressed he
took with the king I thought he was
definitely taking with the Queen which
would have won me the night he means the
opposite of what he said but he that is
true do you think he's gonna see the
knife fork now nope
good yeah he's very fixated on
I think he's pre thought that move and
just as long as it wasn't in jeopardy he
wanted to run it although I see in his
chat down there and he was like oh come
on
because Daniel has coached him he's like
you can do that 96 he could have found
that he could have found it I think just
87 seconds on the clock makes us look
math was an English major numbers are
just words Robert that's true I heard
that it was perfectly sound logic and so
we're gonna go from here
yeah III got no goddamn clue I think I
mean he's got a pawn but that would be
dumb because his knight is hanging
currently I know he did not recognize
that though but you did and we'll
slicker that's the most important
question right now escaped up the night
for that but I have a plan I don't know
what his plan is it might be to just
throw him in check but even if he puts
him in check there's not a piece he can
grab because he'll be defended by the
Queen you're absolutely right so he does
and he goes for the check yeah it looks
like he saw that it would be threatening
the knight but again the knight is
defended by that Queen so you can
usually he was putting parts of it
together but the whole puzzle didn't
come doom so he kind of forgot the Queen
95 would protect the night yeah I mean
unless there's like yes I got a word
just said nevermind oh it wasn't worth I
think that's like saw the board
I saw the position is queen of BN he
just she knows that obviously when the
Queen takes
could be defending it was bad
oh yeah that's uh that's a bummer for
him he looks pretty upset about it
actually
yeah I mean he just kind of bunted away
a pretty decent lead I don't think it's
as big of a deal as he's making it out
to be also I don't know if slicker knows
it's the only piece that's defending his
night right so he makes an on night move
right now that's not a check he'll lose
his knight on c5 justifying criticals
decision yeah yeah I feel like this is
this game the the oh yeah it was good I
mean you can still find the bishop now
right I think that's just what you got
to go for right he's quitting all the
way back which is all Marty's I'm so
long time stressing does that happen you
too when you get to that minute point
Robert I think you saw my stream
yesterday one bullet you're you're a kid
yeah what usually happens is I just lose
and then I cuz I didn't realize I was
low on time and then I swear a couple
times and then and then I look to see if
I got any subs and then I usually don't
and then I start up another one I mean
here in English me your name was me your
swear words or words to thank you thank
you for saying that cuz nobody admits it
simple fact yeah this entire game it
feels like no one's had a super concrete
game plan and they're kind of hoping
that the the opponent makes the game for
them and the thing is they have been but
they just haven't found those specific
moves and slicker just move his knight
to f6 but he's actually bringing his
night towards criticals King and Knight
g4 check will be pretty big disaster oh
and slickered Wow he's on his game right
now
yes liquor has an attack slickers hat
attacks today though I feel like he's
had attacks and my knees gone for them I
don't think I've seen critical go for
one like concrete attack plan uh outside
of that one at the end that right there
that was just a blunder right he went
for it and he went from an opportune
moment and now this key is in check you
only have three moves you know up and he
goes up which is the best move I'd say
because your King actually could start
running away they're not immediately
getting into it
yeah I would find it impossible hard to
find a mate with with a queen night in
Bishop I did see slicker earlier he was
playing an opponent and just throwing
the army the entire force of the United
States at his opponent and that's kind
of how he does checks he doesn't
specifically think of like where can the
king go
it's just throw them in check make sure
that I'm not blundering and eventually
we'll probably get there it's a good
strategy right now because if black
stops checking White's King then all of
a sudden blacks King that can be in some
danger with his Bishop coming to d5 with
checks so I think he's doing the right
thing oh he stopped the checks and what
I say here's Bishop d5 yeah he hasn't
moved the bishop and that checks been
there for a while he sees it and now
he's picking up his men on e4 yeah
easily that's a huge turnaround but they
both have underman and the clocks
slicker no no no not there's not a mate
here if he goes like a 7 there is Oh
second time critical has done this he
hasn't even looked for the other check
yeah picked up the piece which is what I
think it makes sense yeah and this I
don't think that would've been he
couldn't have had a mate solution there
right no there was no force check me
because the King was gonna run out to a
c5 but now there is one yes because the
King s go here and this Queen will come
here well see if he finds it because
easier to say than to play in the game
we are seeing this from a tactic
solution all oh is he going to see that
you can take the Queen good Oh God oh
now that's a turnaround you just why
would you put your queen there there was
no reason Robert what you're doing right
now it was an unsuccessful Queen oh
Jesus I have no idea I wonder if he was
a mouse lip we have him on camera so
let's listen in
I can't believe I did this
he's distraught yeah I mean he doesn't
know but he went from eight and four to
uh almost certainly losing this game I
can't believe I did that
oh what a throw oh I even had time to on
my side would have throw I can't believe
I did but oh that's so sad
well you heard it from his mouth he is
very very sad and yeah yeah
understandably so makes sense and we're
about to have another game by the way so
this match is not over
slicker now we'll get the white pieces
he only needs a drunk in order to win
the match but what do you think about
would critical kind of a plane him in
certain moments of that game I feel like
he has a chance I mean I think there
were several times where they both hand
each other the game and just neither
player took advantage of it until the
very end where it was like critical was
like no no no I insist
please and then just blundered his queen
away so I think it just comes down to
like when he's taking this time to look
at the board and make his move just look
at all the pieces cuz it seems like he
tunnel visions on one piece that he
wants to move and then moves that piece
every time rather than taking you know
black doesn't move the board changes
before you make your move I think it's
fine to think while your opponent's
making their move but after they make
their move that's a different board no
it's a Grilli good point because that's
sort of the problem for newer players is
that they have an idea in mind and
they're so focused on it they get the
tunnel vision and he wanted to go after
his opponents king but putting a queen
on f7 while it looks like it attacks the
pawn because it does but your queen is
now on a vulnerable square and slicker
actually did it sort of the same day
he'll Queen check and then the King
moved and then he was like oh wait a
second this Queen's under attack so if
he made that Queen move in a different
position he may not have won the game
yeah use walked two to the
to the to the take I almost think that
if right there
critical had gone to e5 or something
with this King that he might not have
seen it
like something as simple as that whose
maybe just the fact that he led him
towards the king of the queen of his
eyes right that it was like a no-brainer
oh yeah that's a blundered queen and
slicker only had 22 seconds left so it's
not like he was in the most comfortable
shape here he would have to play a quick
move and you're right he was so focused
on the Queen his own queen that he may
not have taken at me with the bishop
yeah yeah I think that happens a lot and
it feels like the way they play the
opening in just the early game the end
games feel like blitz ends every time
and it doesn't have to I think people
are trying to find tactics where tactics
don't exist where you can just do like
you know I'll say it Robert made
openings where you just advance your
pieces forward alright the chess
principles you can just do all that and
then you should have enough time that
the endgame you can really that's where
you need to spend your time I also love
that you teed it up where you were
telling me you were gonna say something
and you were gonna say it no matter what
my react look I'll say Jess at the
highest level is lame when you take out
the blunders whoa that's the juice
people love the blunders since the guy
was a difference key endgame Manuel who
can play blindfold chess better than
people several hundred rating points
higher than him it's because I can't see
the blunders Robert I can't see the
blunders I dunno slicker loves this
opening I think it's very cheesy it is
and he missed played it because if you
want to go for this you should read your
bishop on c4 to go for the checkmate
he's not even going for the mate no it's
something what he cares about he just
likes taking pieces with this Queen
that's it I saw him play like a couple
games earlier he likes going there and
then hopes that they don't put the
knight and then he just takes and put
him in check and then just just likes to
have like a viscera the right side of
the board that he just enjoyed it's not
even there's no idea of checkmate it's
just kill everything in sight with my
queen well the problem with doing that
is now black critical he put his knight
on d4 which hits the queen hits the
bishop and it's the pawn all at the same
time yeah I think it's bad I know it's
bad in fact to bring
your queen early because of that because
every time your Queens under threat not
only does it allow the other team to
like advance a piece but you also have
to respond by moving the Queen away but
it's still scary I hate it when people
do it to me it's cheesy I know you can
beat it I just don't know how to beat it
all the time so it is it is really
stressful especially if you're not
expecting it right it's new to you then
you're not gonna know exactly the right
way to react and what critical did here
was smart he develops his bishop so he
can castle next move can't complain
about that but it is hard to move to
pieces at the same pace excuse me twice
in an opening yeah he might not find 94
yeah I think slicker is a fiend with the
Queen I don't know if you know this
Robert he was a champion of the raw show
in his day okay truly the king of simps
and he knows how to move that Queen well
I now know that the raw show is the
Austin show that's because alexandra was
on it yesterday yeah yeah and I didn't
watch did you watch I did watch my
roommate was on it she broke his heart
I'll never forgive you Alex I'll never
forgive you
good a picture lot - oh my gosh well I
feel badly for your roommate so this
extend my deepest sympathies over there
but Papa botas was freaking hilarious on
it yeah yeah he was great I love Papa
and you know who Papa bowties picked my
roommate really yeah he said my roommate
was the best slime this his name was the
best choice well we all make mistakes
bow ties gambit once again all right
this seems really good for black for
some reason Robert can you explain cuz I
don't see it so you can bring your night
out into d4 and that still has a good
attack on the Queen attack in the pond
but what the engine is screaming for is
pawn to d5 and the point of this move is
it looks like you're giving away free
pawn but this bishop comes out to g4 and
love it tell me how many safe score is
that Queen at the Queen has has not many
I'll be honest I think the only one is
g3 right exactly and so it's a temporary
pawn sacrifice where my next move is 94
and I'm threatening both 92 with
check and to bring my night here to just
trap this queen are you guys seeing this
are you seeing this in what world I hate
this trampoline thing but could they
have like a trampoline for where's the
gutters
I need the gutters boiling yeah take out
excellent moves from the from the
machines algorithm because it just makes
me feel worse about myself you shouldn't
feel badly about yourself man the
freaking engines are way better than all
of us okay it's true that makes me feel
better that you say you're worse than in
the computer I'm glad I could help your
thanks Robert
you're the emotional state I don't love
a lot of whites positioning mostly
because the night this one and I can't
do anything at all ever and black even
consider taking it to ruin the pawn
structure yeah yeah okay you can't you
can't escape it just has to stay there
and eventually die well that that kind
of minds even Gollum from Lord of the
Rings but he gets off with that another
time that sound very sad
so I mean sick I made a good move Oh
Charlie coming after the Queen he way
he's doing it he's going right after
that Queen he's playing exactly like a
pure one why is that bad why is that
it's so bad in the algorithm dropped
oh yeah that's so hard to find but the
thing the reason why maybe a not the
most civil thing to find normally I
would say yes and that actually was a
good move but he had two pieces under
her attack at the same time so you're
like okay what happens if I move my
knight you just forget about your Bishop
here that's the real problem so if he
takes here he takes him check yes he
still will get it and then he can get
the UH we can't really get much off of
it now right with the night or though
right I'll just get an extra pawn but at
least now his two bishops are under
attack one here and one here so he needs
to do something that protects both and
the only way to do that is by taking
this pawn here we check that make sense
yeah no no make sense I think I think I
just feels like he's playing a little
nervous I will say critical well he is
down one game to none so he has to win
oh then you drop the bishop back
and slicker just steals that piece I
mean yeah that was weird right that's
just a straight-up blunder because the
pond was able to take a knight and a
bishop for nothing
it's an extra piece for slickers a
slicker
he had a lesson when he carved before
this by the way yeah and it seems to be
working out pretty well for slicker
they've both been playing like an
inordinate amount of chess
I think they've both been taking it very
seriously it just feels like tournament
nerves UK rap is the best thing to
listen to it makes you undefeatable do
you get nervous when you're playing in
other non chess events like if you're
playing another game yeah i didäôt like
a Mario part are mario super mario 64
tournament and it was like a relay and I
was incredibly nervous only because I
had a team and if I did poorly like it
was my fault that we would lose but I
have been very nervous throughout this
entire chess tournament and and that's
been weird cuz even like when I competed
in Smash I wouldn't get nervous unless I
was in like a very very tight situation
so in individual games you're just you
don't feel typically feel nervous but
the chess guess yeah yeah even like
going into it like efore I'm freaking
out is efore stupid all of a sudden did
they patch it I don't know anymore what
is it about chess man and gets you all
nervous I think it's maybe I think one
is the stage but two I think a lot of us
just poured a lot of ourselves into
chess we've done a lot of training so
like if we lose it's it's not because we
didn't try we all tried really hard to
win we just tried our best and it wasn't
good enough and that sucks sometimes you
know I mean like if you put yourself out
there and you try your hardest and you
still lose maybe you just suck and that
and that hurts that hurts Wow
now I am starting to feel like a degree
of empathy towards you before I came in
this was like an animus now I feel like
that was tough to hear but my English
major ways I'm
in your mind with my words I feel like
that's probably true I put a lot of
Scrabble but you have the major so you
got this this isn't I'm moist critical
so nobody has to hear me talk anymore
sure so quiet he's solid man like he's
borderline inconsolable it seems it is
crazy that this was the same man who
went on for a fair bit probably the most
I've seen on Twitch about his throbbing
yeah I was gonna repeat those words but
yeah I remember that clip no but so did
I feel like they were trading barbs at
least you were talking smack to each
other and there's no doubt in my mind
that critical wants no part of a loss
can't figure out any tactics oh yeah
absolutely it doesn't feel good to lose
critical was poised as the the favorite
right I assumed it was for King so I
think he was a favorite but I think he
was the favorite so I mean that stings
even more but I thought slicker just
gets in people's head to CGM Daniel dart
it's key chilling and criticals chat
tried a backseat game it he seems a
little frustrated about it we talked
about this 1,000 times did you not see
Charlie's tribute to Daniel I quit I did
you call him the Prophet so if he's
gonna be the Prophet I think with
Charlie's pledge driving me nuts but I
believe the ideals acting like the rest
of twitchchat he's like the rest of us
we just want to call out the moves and
now that means chats about just to spam
one of us can't wait for it I'm learning
you know I'm learning this whole twitch
lingo you know all you got to do is farm
email it's that's it at the end of the
day if you ever not sure what to say you
just say hey this is a sad situation for
critical and then you got Shaq covered
for like 45 seconds got it you know
recharge and figure out what to say
after that exactly
and now you know streaming and there
goes one of us I see it all happening we
did I don't I'll be honest I'm trying to
play as critical I'm trying to play as
black I'm just God's Way of you pure raw
instinct I guess playing off of pure raw
instinct is what he's gone with and yeah
it is hard because he's down a piece and
there's no clear play for him he has the
rook on d8 so he may want to try to use
the default maybe double his rooks
that's probably one plan that I would
think about but you're absolutely right
that there is no obvious plan for black
there are some all eight points so your
pieces don't have the freest play yeah
and his pawns on the on the C E and G
file are brutal
they just prevent his like Knight from
moving in without having to do like two
or three moves right and that's a
misreading yeah in general in chess if a
pawn is three squares away from a knight
like this point is it takes away that
nice for jumping possibilities so I
always mentioned this when I'm covering
chest upon three squares wait for night
is almost always a good thing I test are
dumb cuz it's always you always have
like a qualifier at the end like control
the setter always no no set this one
time those are principle use that idea
not laws oh look like that move my
slicker this should be too is coming
it's like pirates I guess I don't think
Pirates of the Caribbean it's like not
it's more like guidelines right and
everything in that movie is guideline is
generous for everything that happened in
that movie but and should pretty much a
documentary I was gonna give a shout out
to cash out for the twenty gifted subs
thank you so much for supporting the
channel you know I have to answer
messages that you can't see
alright my life is not easy they drop
twenty gifted man it's a hundred bucks
it's like a multi-million whereas my
where's a drop a Honda if you're trying
to flex you know I mean cash up Jesus
I'm just I'm just Mont same when I'm
told all right this is not me you think
I would ever shout somebody for so you
drop a hundred then we can talk about
you know I'll start I'll bring the siren
I'll drop my easy buttons why I'm hash
up I brought up the 20 because you
almost lost 20 yesterday when you were
saying he's not gonna make he's gonna
make just move for sure that in me that
is true that did almost happened but hey
that's the good thing about stalling is
that you can never ever get screwed over
as long as you don't finish your
sentences it's true
but as a person who majored in the major
you chose maybe being one more eloquent
is good too I think both players should
just try stacking on the D file it's the
only open one with their rooks I think
that's it right yeah I'd probably try to
go over to d7 rook to d8 something like
that
anyways Knight to d7 he's really
struggling to find any sort of idea but
this is actually quite good because the
knight walk might come to f8 and then
it's a six and then you have squares to
actually jump into yeah
and I would say love you can correct me
if I'm wrong these kind of backwards
like moves it don't seem to do anything
right away are ones that are really hard
to play like Knight to d7 was the
purpose of that but if he can keep
rewriting at night maybe finally it will
find the light of day I think it's just
really frustrating that you have to do
like three moves to be in a spot that's
good
and I often times like I just I want to
be in the good spot but since his pawns
are all kind of garbage he has to do
like so many he's just to jump around
the entire mat because the knight moves
all wonky it does it's a slow moving
piece and I guess that's why he brought
the knight back was he was protecting
the g5 palm with his queen so that he
could play h5 and open this for his rook
pretty good idea yeah I like opening it
up I think it's it's way too tight I
don't think anyone's gonna be able to
find a way out through this just pawn
wall on the on the fourth and fifth you
call them ranks when they're this way
yeah ranks ranks but what about this way
the files fine okay ranks and files okay
yeah I like it I think is I think is
genius you just called critical Oh
genius love it I think critical is so
much better than he's playing I've
played against critical uh and I don't
know for some reason it feels like the
moment he bxq see like it was like that
Space Jam scene or it zaps some of his
powers cuz like I played him in like a
10-5 and he was really good and then I
played him in a three Oh like the day
after he beat xqc and he was like I
don't know man Daniel said to play three
O's man he said I gotta be I don't know
man I gotta go I gotta go and I was like
okay okay it was like bad I was like
what's going on I I think he psyched
himself out I think he maybe his
expectations got Rui raised or something
I don't know what's going on with him
but I hope he uh he manages to find some
composure in this game where the
Monstars in this equation in this whole
space train wreck
obviously slicker is the mod stars
because they're so small they have to
take the power to become huge yep they
steal Sean Bradley and they become
seven-foot
six or however tall exactly exactly so
night of three by slicker he's coming
after g5 now so both of these players
are doing really good moves at this
point yeah and I guess the question is
is critical going to protect his pawn or
is he gonna swing his rook over to h8
and go for white king or can you just
move your rook to like h3 flock in a
place to then bring him over yeah rook
h3 so you're attacking the knight and
mines the queen but then I could
probably take on G fight with my queen
so you were pinning it and I get a trade
Queen's this way it's not the end of the
world but yeah white straight Queens oh
yes yes yes yes he of course course
course course I think that's hard to see
I will say yeah he just did six with a
stronger piece first it's not something
I would do naturally
that makes sense it really does and just
for the record I know I give you some
attitude every now and then there's no
suggestion you can make them chess board
that I would ever make fun of so I'm
just gonna say that I love I firmly
believe that when you're looking at a
chess board and like you're studying
you're not playing it that you should be
coming up with as many ideas as possible
even if they don't work it's worse to
not think of them in the first place mmm
they're saying you kind of like like me
like we're cool now
yeah we're cool oh cool cool cool it
seems like people are dropping their
5000 highlighted redeem messages yeah I
saw that didn't understand what it is
it's it's this new system that twitch
added where you just get points for
being at a channel twitch is the world's
best company at farming people who are
already watching twitch to watch twitch
more and spend more money on twitch and
so drop that 5k boys you earned it I
mean it's it's nonstop and it's just
it's never-ending you can drop your
chest calm naca h3 underscore s geez
drop your chest calm hold up I got to
get the full thing drop your chest calm
naka underscore whatever it is the one
of the glasses if you're rooting for
slicker and then one with the finger
under his chin
if you're rooting for critical you're
just controlling the chat now but it's
got to be highlighted or else it doesn't
count
oh uh huh thank you then gifted Ludwig
app and pretty cool wow what a cool
sounding app Robert I'd love to talk
about it more but I do want to see what
critical thinking of huge shout-outs of
love again you kidding me know what I'm
talking about that we're gonna be look
I'm doubt we got to talk about love yeah
because it is changing the game I can't
tell you what it does yet but it is good
is it similar to Ludwig chess calm it
yes yes it's similar to Ludwig chess
calm but infused with cash app I would
call it the uber of chess oh yeah
now we're getting places is what we're
going for here and speeding and getting
places all of a sudden critical has
taken this pawn h3 and this King on g1
is feeling awfully unprotected here now
that the h3 pawn is gone g4 is under
attack good move by slicker here let's
tune into critical to hear his thoughts
as he is down the clock and he's in a
must-win situation
he's so quiet again I think everything
comes down to like confidence in your
moves and I I know I think critical
feels probably how I feel when I'm in
spots like this and it's just every
single move I feel super not confident
at all like I'm a dumb idiot don't be so
hard on yourself we have to be because
the alternative is we like we lose and
then when you lose everybody types sad
fart of twitch in your stream and then
it feels bad Robert you don't understand
I do understand because the shadows
relentless even at often grandmasters so
it happens all of us feel better but
criticals position is getting better for
sure yeah he's made us to get like a
couple pieces out Wow get a load of this
guy
what the what the gopher crazy play here
1:36 do a four pawn to a4 it's a good
idea actually because you trying to open
up the a file for your pieces yeah also
get my queen out look what he's doing
he's bringing his knight around I do
like that if his Knight ends up on em
for that's yeah that's the chef's kiss
right mm-hmm I think this is the best
chess critical is played obviously from
a full game perspective no but in the
last I don't know 10 moves after he lost
the piece it feels like he's really
maneuver it extremely well yeah this
spot for both of them just seems like
miserably difficult and like piteous and
so many just small movements that feel
wrong but all right that's a really good
assessment of the position it's all
about the maneuvering these little most
slickers move was great Queen to d3
because if the knight moves away he'll
bring us Queen all the way down a d7
trading off the Queen's there and going
after blacks King
just making everything about your moves
lovely yeah yeah he she definitely well
so to be clear my move would have been
done on a different board so I could
have taken with the uh yeah not useless
critical obviously didn't mean that
something your movies get attention
somewhere I just don't know what I can't
do anything back here I can't just move
the nether than come down here and
exchange one rook you can't and then we
go down I pulled that defender away
maybe I just do that I'm real long time
that's I think one of the good things
about your a-form move are you kidding
me was back
reads policy for now is not well
protected that pawn was on b3 and was
protecting c4 once it captured the Queen
on e6 is aiming right at that c4 ball
yeah that's what I originally wanted to
do unfortunately he just did it after
the Queen already moved to protect it
but it would have been hanging and so he
could have gotten a bit of tempo I still
like the idea of bringing the night in I
feel like he was doing it and then quit
but that night there just seems amazing
he should do it right now this is an
opportune moment bring the 90 g6 bring
it in to f4 or hits the Queen hits this
rook here and slicker it was smart to
bring his knight back because he's
trying to protect his King this is also
a good move by critical hitting this g4
pawn this is a very tense position yeah
yeah I think the worst part about this
is criticals like anti NIM in the sense
that when the time starts to get low it
gets bad for him yeah NIM is a beast in
time pressure and okay brought the night
out here's the knight coming into f4
yeah it was cool slicker almost like
motivate him to do it oh I guess you had
to yeah yeah sucker did kind of bait him
into it I'm looking look at critical go
yeah took the pawn that he opened up
with his useless move not so useless now
ha buddy oh my gosh he's he's giving his
finger check and his bishop was hanging
and the Kings in big troll 904 play 904
oh I think he was too concerned about
the pawn I could just push up the pawn
or you basically take a rook four pawn
here but if white pushes up the pawn
black shouldn't let why go get a queen
and try to checkmate the King instead
this King is in big danger yeah yeah I
like the idea of it I just think to
switch from the mindset of play good
chest take pieces protect King -
checkmate is a pretty big jump and I
just hope he sees it well he this move
ago he brought his rook down so I assume
he's going for a sort of checkmate idea
and slicker brings his rook back to g1
and look at critical go he gives his
check here and his night on e - oh oh oh
quench it takes nice mate is he gonna
see that oh that's fine it's still he's
still in a mating scenario and he still
has like a little bit of tempo here he
is let's let's bring critical back on
just to see if he can finish off his
game oh he's doing it
he can't draw here oh he does see that
finally he does which means you
checkmate him yeah does it there it is
BAM you baby 51 seconds on the clock
that's gotta hurt that doesn't feel good
does it slicker you just that's so huge
man oh he got greedy with my pawns I'm
glad that my little gambit paid off
Jesus alright so lately he was very
stressed in that moment and yeah he's
right that slicker got distracted by
some of his pawns and then he was able
to get an attack and eventually deliver
checkmate so it's funny because slicker
his moves were quite good throughout
this entire game yeah I think slicker
played great actually I would probably
chop it up to one move Robert that
really changed this game in White's
favor and it was the H pawn boot or the
a pawn move it was the a five to a four
move and then that that kind of uh left
the Queen to move to c4 eventually and
then it also allowed swickert slickers
to start making a push which which ended
up being like a big mistake his downfall
you're right and we are getting a
tie-break it's going to be a three
minute boots game where right now it is
Charlie critical getting the white
pieces so he'll get the first move with
three minutes pure blitz and because of
lovelies great suggestion with pawn to
a4 late producer can we add the GM title
no not in there can we just can we skim
the GM so that was a great suggestion
give it to me you deserve all can we
call every time a pawn on the black side
moves from a five to a four no matter
what the scenario is the lot of it
gambit can we do that I think we can
it's a great move and you you know you
saw that you were loosening up the
defense in this phone and c4 and that
was actually critical to how well
critical one I said critical then I was
like this this is yeah you get this GM
shit's easy boys I'm telling you Jess
I've been here for like two weeks it
don't take a whole lifetime don't worry
about it just spend a couple
every day you don't I mean it's like
brushing your teeth wait why is there
not so there can you remove the nut from
the wheel of real cool producers alright
farm your Lal dog will use the Lord we
cap will fight back we will sue we do
have the power of litigation on our side
I'm so glad my sister's a lawyer right
now I'm nervous about a three out four
critical you think that in the Blitz
it's goes to slickers favor he's so slow
and I think the waste liquor place to I
guess it'll be black so it's a little
different but just with his aggressive
Queen it's something that like not
learned he car doesn't say hey sometimes
they just bring out their queen and move
their queen around for 15 turns and so
you have to think about every single
thing that slickers Queens gonna do it
slows you down a lot I'm nervous he
plays slow I feel like slicker has the
edge here I would agree that he plays
very quickly so even if his moves aren't
gonna be often actually hit car says a
lot about his own games a good fast move
is better than the best move you played
slowly so just conserving your time is
important and there's Nassif's liquor
was still there because he's in a dark
room every time he's streaming and then
I saw him when he changed his scene
alright we have liftoff okay we're into
it it is the first blitz game you've
ever had the honor of commentating it is
the first blitz game I saw you
compensating it earlier it seems a
little hectic it's a lot slower when
you're playing it but when you're
watching it the moves are just flying
out they are it's cuz you're not
thinking about the game in sense of how
you're playing you're saying they're
watching oh this looks interesting notes
as you run the pressure being on so the
green trade is offered in screen ooh
declined clickers is no which is
probably bad for slicker because
Charlie's Bishop is not an open diagonal
I think it's incredibly Blatt a bad I
think any time you're doing a three oh
you just take your trade and you get to
endgame as soon as possible at least
that's the way I play it and it seems to
get me the most success because
otherwise you to think in that sucks
thinking sucks you heard it from Ludwick
first but you're right because when you
have little time and then you're just
thinking between four different moves
and which one is best then you get
rattled and you don't make any movie
gets decision paralysis so I agree with
you that having look what Charlie
rinkle is lining up on this 96 he has an
actual plan here it feels like slickers
just been moving fast look at this back
line it's like all his pieces in a row
finally moves one but uh it's not the
worst threat in the world could just
move it didn't need to do that though
yes step into a pin so probably not look
at slick or go into a discovery as well
yeah this is bad for him now he probably
has to just put his Bishop back to d3
play move like that but it's not
comfortable here at all
yeah it'd be hard to find that move I
feel like he might end up going
somewhere like he won with his Queen to
keep his knight defendant to keep your
knight defended yeah it is a shame that
he pinned himself he could have just
moved the knight out of the way but
again it is three oh he decides to go
from pain to pain which that that yeah
that made no sense
oh just liquor movie too quickly at that
moment could have taken this and
critical sees it so he brings about to
protect tonight I mean but what a
blessing like he that all hinged on
slicker just not taking advantage of a
bad spot you put yourself look at the
left bar the computer is upset at the
amount of work it has to do here
did you see b5 was bad because the
bishop could take it and then critical
made us move in 0.9 seconds yeah either
pre moving there not caring about what
the other person is doing they're just
doing their move and it's hard to play
blitz because you keep glancing at the
clock every single timing oh this move
wait I know you look the move let me
look at the clock you're freaking out
and McGirt not grabbing this free night
there is a free night and it's been here
this computer again is it's worrying
it's not meant for the faint of heart
it's not meant for this level of play I
think it's perfect for this level of
play let's listen in on critical because
this is a tough moment for him and I'd
love to hear him think through
he's so quiet he just continues to be
silent he's up on top which is a
surprise to me that that was a good move
that he just played okay
he can take sure I love this he did that
really quickly yeah and if he checks the
King he when he wins the Queen oh oh my
gosh criticals on fire right now and he
took with King so you could do another
similar back rank thing taking the rook
again it's true good point that if you
get another check on the back rank down
goes dive rook on h8 ooh I'll just trade
here just trade don't even worry about
it you're up you're up so much up a
queen I think in this spot when you're
playing three oh yeah trading would have
been good I think he wants a checkmate
slicker though that is a bit of he's a
bit of a greedy Gavin then and he's
playing really well he's ahead on the
clock by quite a substantial margin I
think you'll see like Bishop b2 or
something I think he wants like frying
this rook yep Bishop e2 would've been a
good move and say so you can bring the
Queen all the way in there
and you can tell he's nervous because
he's a talker and he's being real quiet
I just gave him the pond grab it
nice took it and then also threatening
the rook this is good slicker kind of
walked him into that which is sick for
him and slicker has unrealistic or that
that's great too oh no nevermind yeah
well so I hated see it I didn't see it
either
oh god I see it oh my gosh right is it
no Tommy you can you can grab you can
grab that pawn is that mate no the king
can run is like yeah just gonna fall
he takes the rook now and he's got 25
seconds he just saw the rook now he gets
the yeah yeah and the good thing about
having advantage here is even if he
doesn't win from mate he's just gonna
win because he's gonna put him in check
and slicker camp pre-move just don't
repeat the move oh no oh my god you're
scaring me he was gonna do it and he
probably realized that he can't take a
repetition he's got a rook - you can use
your rook here bring the pawn up one
more
that's gonna be it bang you got it oh
well it's a real greaser baby
Oh oh my gosh that is the first time
I've won on time ever close Wow
I think it's a sign of respect if
critical is cursing at your expense that
means he probably likes you yeah yeah I
think that's what that means Robert you
are nailing it again on the English word
and the language I will say I think he
played great I'm shocked at how fast
he's able to play moves obviously he had
a couple blessings that slicker didn't
see but that's what that's the fun of
three oh that's why three owes fun is
because there are going to be minimum
five blunders on each side and it's all
about who's able to spot him and move
the quickest for sure and we will bring
critical and slick around for an
interview so we'll be back in a bit
stay tuned everybody four more chests
like count pogchamp coverage and we are
back with both critical and slicker so
critical first and foremost shout out to
you because that was an epic comeback I
was lucky I was real lucky it was
against anyone besides slicker I think I
think I was definitely but I mean we're
going up against Johnny sins over there
made a lot of mistakes overlooked a lot
of good tactics listen listen listen
okay um I stopped to rob one okay you
know it's like let me just tell you this
right now what happened that the star
was just like warm up you know like when
it's doggy style and it flips then you
take control you know y'all take control
that's what happened you know I'll let
you off enough wait that's why you i
facepalm in bro you know that's why
that's what hot to me Oh guys analogies
I do want to ask talking
he's just [__] stage just a
commentator this man is he's got just
books bro can you even
this man is reading like Blonsky Orson
listen mate listen listen I beat look
like he's gonna be easy
unfortunately you just got the easiest
one of your life whoever's gonna go
through you've won
you've won congratulations you lose no
I'll say that you stay oh listen listen
I'm coming across as an evil man you
know I'm not an evil man I swear to God
all right
I love humans I love you you know you
know about time waste you know maybe I
was T and maybe I was a bit hungry and
thirsty for that but then no I backed
out a bit right
I was I do I do I need to and I
remembered one thing what do you
remember
I don't know but anyway good good that
was those a surprise comeback he did the
the second round I took the bishop I
don't know whether you came out with
that retaliation
it was surprised I can't believe it
actually worked man I was genuinely
panicking it was so the formation I saw
there was something similar to one of
those puzzles and Daniel has me working
like a madman I'm like puzzles so
something I recognized and just got
lucky that it panned out that way that
Daniel guy litchi stream sniped his
stream snipe take Amaru
and then he tried to counter our play so
I had to come up with a standard play I
had to cope with any play not like I've
remembered the jicama return lesson he
told me well I had to come over the
random place so it was you making some
high IQ plays man I was sweating hard
but to be fair to be fair
hikaru only teaches like the day of on
people I play against so you got lucky
her car who's got in for me listen try
me horrid listen listen don't know if
you know who I am I don't need people
teach me how to play when I was when I
was seven years old we tell his story
when I was seven years old right on to
school I said my mom got me food in the
snow for my part lunch and he used to go
to school and I eat outside and stuff
then come back home PC was ready I used
to
counter strike source in fact that sigh
that's hypothetically incorrect 1.6 okay
I used to practice and practice and pray
no one taught me I was a mastermind at
that game I became global elite in no
time and then ESL pros wanted to hit me
up I had to decline them because my mom
refused these sort of interactions with
gaming's unfortunately um boy all aside
that's completely irrelevant while I was
saying um but I don't need to be coached
okay so akaru okay you hands I don't
need no training
I need a training no okay you need a
training to win critical Dania was in
your chat saying that he believed in you
like throughout most of the match you
really every step of the way telling you
what move you should have done and said
we've run this a thousand times
when I he held faith the whole way
through okay well like I said when when
a slicker did not stick to the hikaru
special the hikaru dirty strats he threw
me off and I started to panic a little
bit so I just tried to play like a
normal game I think what we'd open it
was actually pretty smart cuz I don't
think any of us prep for that I don't
think he car whoever says yeah they
might just whip out their queen and move
that around three times so I think is
actually smart and uh and he did have a
lead game two to just made a great
comeback yeah that's pretty awesome this
Daniel was there though he was supposed
to be teaching like a chess camp to
underprivileged kids or something I'm
glad you kind of bailed on that to talk
to me them kids
my main man Johnny sins aka Charlie so
you defendant
he's unbiased I think you played the
best you could and you came out here and
you put on a great job you know you know
all aside you know the gaming was fun
boys you know like you know chess
evolved like when I was a kid my needs
to hang around with the hood rats you
get me my needs to do little rubbery
grandma come on give me up purse well
then teach s nah man I never seen my
life like that so like from you know
rubbing the Grammys to going on chess is
like a different life for me I
just come for that you know it was I'm a
shock because you know from all my life
I've been labeled as a brown risk you
know those people that think I'm a brown
risk you know robbing a grandmother I'm
sorry I didn't mean to interject money
you don't know about my life like moving
to chess is like it's a different world
you know a shout out to hash out to
Hickory shorter hands shorter Alex you
know she'll tell everyone I competed
there's a good run you know a loser
isn't loser when you see a loser
so loses like a chess nerd wait I'm not
dissing you guys oh boy I did not last
question for you is having listened to
that Tupac biggie 95 freestyle yet oh
you don't see what last time you said
that to me and I was um ADHD kicked in
when you said I've heard of freestyle
yes
runnin right I believe you
yeah it's called runnin the song's
called running Lydian to park that's
fake as a remix as a remix oh yeah when
in the dining table and he's drinking it
says freestyle oh my god
you just called me out
you caught you were just hating on
everybody critical hey man you did good
thanks man you gave slicker the business
I've been a big sticker friend from day
one because he's hilarious he's so
hilarious but I'm actually met but you
actually played really well and to come
back from that while you were clearly
nervous and quite quiet on your stream
it was really impressive my but my
microphone was Mia please go ahead get
out of here
don't kick me don't kick me now we're
kicking you wait wait my microphone was
muted that's why I didn't get to talk I
said
did you hear what I said about Tupac I
don't listen to you even when you do
talk do you that house okay rains we
chase I mean without no yeah I go no
singer you know I like you man
so we we we love you all mom you know P
so remember this quoted remember before
I leave the quotes before this is John
marksman 1962 said beautiful yes are you
gonna be here for this I mean just is
this bro beefing but seriously though
Congrats on the win you will place to
play the winner of Ludwig and xqc
tomorrow so do you've any final thoughts
on that before we send you both on your
way
no man looking forward to it I'll see
you soon Ludwig in the finals alright
guys thanks for joining us thanks man
[Music]